[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur LCP on se retrouve
comme chaque semaine autour d'un plat
d'un dessert et d'un invité pour parler
alimentation agriculture écologie mais
aussi politique et cette semaine nous
recevons marine Tondelier bonjour et
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
merci à vous pour présenter cette
émission Jean-Pierre Montagné bien sûr
bonjour Jean-Pierre bonjour Brigitte
bonjour marine tondeuillier bonjour
alors vous êtes secrétaire national
d'Europe Écologie Les Verts depuis 5
mois élu avec plus de 90% des suffrages
vous avez remplacé Julien Bayou vous
êtes également conseillère régional des
Hauts de France depuis 2021 est
conseillère municipal d'opposition
d'Hénin-Beaumont depuis 2014 ville
actuellement dirigée par le frontiste
Steve Briois vous défendez une ligne
radicale chez les écolos au point de
soutenir les actions de désobéissance
civile des jeunes militants écologistes
vous êtes contre la chasse que vous
souhaitez interdire le dimanche et
contre les retenues d'eau vous avez
d'ailleurs manifesté à Sainte Soline
engagé jusqu'au bout des ondes vous
l'êtes aussi pour votre région vous la
native du Pas-de-Calais avec un menu
très très Ch'tis
avec une sauce au fromage du coin le
maroilles et on desserre des crêpes à la
vergeoise dans le dessous des plats la
crise du bio les ventes chutes est-ce
durables ou passagers on pose la
question dans cette émission dans les
pieds dans le plat c'est méga poulailler
de la discorde un des milliers de poulet
bon marché élevés en batterie au
détriment du bien-être animal reportage
à suivre allez on passe à table tout de
suite cuisine et confidence
alors d'abord marine tour de liée je
voulais saluer votre courage politique
pas facile à notre époque celui qui est
d'assumer ses frites au maroilles vous
auriez pu comme d'autres personnalités
vertes invitées ici tomber dans la
caricature de l'écolo au menu soupe
vegan non vous prenez le contre-pied pas
de tout quinoa comme vous l'avez dit ni
de vieillesse céréales ressuscité non
votre assiette n'est pas politique vous
vous lâchez Brigitte 200% plaisir avec
des frites certes du Nord votre terroir
mais trop souvent diabolisé que l'espace
d'un repas vous réhabiliter bravo et on
a encore rien vu ces patates gorgées
d'huile Brigitte on va les trop-pouiller
dans une sauce à la crème et au fromage
et au maroilles hérétique ce n'est plus
un repas marine Tondelier mais une orgie
je me dis qu'avec de pareils on vit à
table vous êtes démasqué vous avez
définitivement tiré un trait sur
l'écologie punitive et c'est votre
assiette qui nous le dit est-ce que je
me trompe
il se trouve que pour le coup je suis
végétarienne depuis 2009 que ça fait
très longtemps que je mange plus de
viande pas que pour des raisons
climatiques pour le coup j'ai jamais
trop aimé la viande en vrai et et je me
forçais quand j'étais petite comme
beaucoup et puis quand j'ai vu qu'en
plus c'était pas bon pour le climat j'ai
arrêté et les gens en 2009 à
Hénin-Beaumont c'était assez subversif
d'être végétarien et donc une grande
famille d'agriculteurs et tous les gens
disent mais comment tu fais qu'est-ce
que tu manges il me regarde genre ça
doit vraiment être horrible ta vie enfin
bon courage et moi je dis mais non tout
va bien et donc voilà j'ai toujours
beaucoup aimé manger je mange aussi du
quinoa tout ce que vous avez cité je
mange pas de tofu ça m'intéresse jamais
attiré et moi j'aime pas tout ce qui est
très transformé donc par exemple tous
les trucs les substitutifs à la viande
qui sont quand même en forme de steak et
de saucisse avec tout ce qui est très
très transformé très agroalimentaire
j'aime pas trop ça donc je préfère les
choses très simples très efficaces et
qui font plaisir quand même donc la
frite c'est un peu pour compenser le
fait de pas manger de viande ça fait
plaisir c'est ma première langue donc si
vous voulez quand vous êtes dans le
Pas-de-Calais on en mange toutes les
semaines depuis tout petit qu'elle a
chaque famille son jour de tradition des
frites alors vous c'était le quel jour
dans votre famille c'était plutôt le
week-end avec le poulet ou voilà un soir
chez mes grands-parents c'est le samedi
midi les frites et puis c'était vraiment
dans la ferme familiale
l'arrière-grand-mère qui est plus chez
les patates ma grand-mère qui faisait
les frites et qui les fait encore ce
jour-là parfois il y a une baraque à
frites maintenant en face donc parfois
ils vont les acheter en fait il y a une
vraie tradition de la baraque à frites
chez vous
c'est pas on fait les deux c'est
autorisé mais voyez les paracrites pour
moi je mange pas de viande pour 2 euros
50 avec la sauce j'ai j'ai même pas un
petit et vous avez à manger pour trois
jours et c'est les poules qui m'aident à
finir parce que même avec une petite
frite on a assez à manger et donc c'est
hyper populaire c'est très convivial
vous pouvez ça prend pas de temps voilà
cuisiner et pour le coup quand on a
envie des gens à manger bah c'est aussi
des choses qui sont rapides à faire dans
toutes les campagnes de campagne en
général ça se finit avec les frites dans
mon jardin surtout au moment du
confinement où tous les restaurants
étaient fermés enfin voilà c'est
vraiment une tradition de partage aussi
et pour le coup ça ressemble à notre
région avec modération parce que c'est
quand même le symbole un peu de la
malbouffe malheureusement
est-ce qu'on peut manger des bonnes
frites parce que je discutais avec vous
hors caméra parce qu'effectivement les
frites elles sont chez Françoise elles
sont excellentes elles sont très bonnes
mais est-ce qu'il y a une vraie vie
comme dans le Nord à Paris si on aime
les frites oui et il y a des endroits
pour moi je vous avoue que moi c'est pas
à Paris que je les mange mais oui il y a
des il y a des bons coins à un frit à
Paris mais si vous passez dans le Nord
il y a des classements des meilleures
friteries de France et la numéro 4 du
classement bienvenue chez nous et
Thaïlande Beaumont il y a aussi
l'estaminet du ferrailleur il y a il y
avait une très bonne friterie qui
s'appelait chez Gonzalez qui était ma
collègue d'ailleurs avec qui on a fait
quelques campagnes électorales enfin
voilà c'est mais il y a beaucoup de très
bonnes frites c'est quoi une bonne frite
pour vous est-ce qu'elle doit être à lui
mettre ou un peu plus large est-ce
qu'elle doit être très croquante est-ce
que ah bah en fait c'est déjà on voit si
les yeux non mais on voit si elle est
surgelés ou pas à la manière dont elle
est coupée
je ne me prononce nptv comme on dit
nationale mais mais voilà il y a ce truc
là il y a à l'ancienne on voyait comme
les personnes les plus chez les patates
derrière dans les dans les grosses
poubelles la pleine d'eau pour mettre
les plonger les pommes de terre dans
l'eau après il y a escale et cuite à la
au au bah c'est les vrais alors ça moi
je suis végétarienne pas y compris par
sensiblement je mange des frites au gras
de bœuf peut-être très mal mais c'est
comme ça d'ailleurs pour la santé
personnellement voilà les frites
authentiques c'est ça après il y a moi
j'aime bien mettre du vinaigre aussi sur
des frites ce qui est une hérésie pour
certains mais qui dansent locale là
aussi ça se fait beaucoup dans le dans
le Nord
c'est assez faut même chez soi il faut
faire les deux cuissons et puis après il
y a ce qu'on fait après la frite parce
qu'on est colo donc on travaille le
cycle de vie du produit et donc vous
rappelez que Julien Bayou avait fait
voter à l'Assemblée nationale un
amendement pour permettre le recyclage
de lutte de friture et notamment
aujourd'hui on peut faire rouler des
vidéos
en fait mais c'est interdit parce que
bah il y a le lobby derrière de partir
dans le Nord-Pas-de-Calais La Voix du
Nord ça leur a fait trois jours de voilà
les friterie du Nord réhabilité et
c'était un moment en plus vous savez
entre le covid la guerre en Ukraine
enfin il y avait beaucoup d'inflation
c'était dur et aussi pour les baraques à
frites c'est il y avait le prix des
huiles qui avaient flambées je sais pas
si vous rappelez et donc c'était un peu
le moment de fierté nationale chez nous
voilà alors vous dites que vous voulez
manger avec de quelque chose donc là
c'est une sauce au maroilles et sinon là
c'est un peu la fête quand il y a la
sauce du mariage au Maroc
pas mal mais après il y a les sauces
vous savez
ils ont même des choses donc c'est des
sauces industriels ça mouraï Hannibal
etc et maintenant ils font la sauce
Tuche la sauce ch'ti il y a des dérivés
quand même alors c'est quoi votre
préférée vous moi j'aime bien la sauce
Hannibal et il y a quoi là dedans c'est
très bizarre je crois que je ne veux pas
le savoir
vous allez pas lire la composition mais
ça fait partie voilà mais moi j'aime
bien la sauce au maroilles c'est
original vous pouvez la faire chez vous
c'est pas très je peux vous donner
quelques astuces pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas le Maroilles
non parce que nous on n'a pas l'habitude
du Maroilles c'est quand même un fromage
du Nord du Nord alors il faut prendre ma
ton bien bon Maroilles ce qu'il tombe
sous le sens quand même oui mais il y a
vraiment des Maroilles avec AOC AOP donc
c'est un patrimoine très bien gardé dans
le Nord donc la recette à proprement dit
en fait c'est très simple vous coupez le
fromage en petits dés vous le faites
fondre avec de la crème un peu de poivre
de muscade je sais pas si c'est votre
cas dans votre famille pour la relever
un peu vous remuez bien et vous obtenez
cette sauce très lisse un cas
parfaitement fait Françoise alors
vous pouvez le faire avec tous les
fromages
moins calorique on peut rajouter du lait
à la place de la crème et du coup mettre
un peu de maïzena pour qu'elle prenne et
alors si il en reste après les frites
gardez là parce que c'est aussi très bon
matondi avec un filet mignon de porc ou
même un lapin je suis bloqué
les spectateurs qui ne sont pas tous
vegan et donc vous vous en faites très
souvent des des
Maroilles parce que c'est quand même une
grande spécialité locale non j'en fais
pas très souvent je mange beaucoup de
fromage mais je suis pas des sauces au
moral tous les jours après sachez que la
tradition du Nord parce que le Maroc
la tarte au Maroilles qui là pour le
coup j'en ai beaucoup mangé quand
j'étais petite et alors il la tradition
c'est il y a les 20 km de Maroilles
parce que Maroilles c'est une ville
gagner le 20 km de Maroilles vous gagnez
votre poids en Maroilles mais en général
le mec qui gagne des 20 km de Maroilles
je pense que son entraînement lui
interdit même si les redistribué
partage mais voilà c'est une vraie
tradition c'est pas du Pas-de-Calais
Maroilles pour écouter du Nord et de la
tirage du Sud du Nord et du nord de
laine mais c'est un endroit très précis
vous en prenez au petit déjeuner comme
dans les Ch'tis ou non pas chez vous il
m'arrive de manger du fromage au petit
déjeuner mais pas le Maroilles mais pour
le coup voilà c'est aussi un fromage
assez identitaire vous êtes gourmande
mais excusez mais beaucoup cuisiner
aussi est-ce que ça va passer parfois ça
va te plaire mais parfois on peut très
bien aimer l'assiette et pas les
fourneaux vous avez compris
donc ça c'est toujours compliqué bon ça
c'est pas compliqué il y avait un long
week-end là on a eu plusieurs et donc
j'ai eu plaisir de pouvoir cuisiner un
peu et c'est sympa de alors vous faites
quoi par exemple qui me réclame en plus
des recettes très précises donc je fais
les recettes très précises alors vous
avez fait quoi si vous avez pu alors lui
il voulait en hot-dog
je l'ai pas mangé mais je l'ai fait
avec une saucisse de chez Biocoop j'ai
fait un risotto aux asperges feta oignon
rouge gouda
asperges Monster j'ai fait des pizzas
vous avez une bonne recette ouais bah il
faut mettre le
compléter vous faites le bouillon avec
les épluchures d'asperges bien sûr vous
récupérez pour faire
il faut qu'il soit quand même
mais vous pouvez faire d'autres choses
en même temps ajouter
et les enfants aiment bien faire ça
parce qu'il faut surveiller il faut
voilà on cuisine en famille chez vous
rajoutez le reste à la fin et voilà
c'est parfait il y a un repas ça
réchauffe très bien pour le coup
contrairement aux frites donc vous
pouvez en faire pour trois jours oui ah
non je trouve que c'est même ça se
bonifie il y a des bains nous en général
il y en a plus à la fois
il devient un peu un peu Bastogne
pas très attention calories si je peux
me permettre en fait non mais après pour
le coup je mange beaucoup c'est comme
j'ai pas souvent le temps en fait je
mange beaucoup de choses qui ne se
cuisent pas et donc je fais beaucoup de
salades composées de trucs avec
la saison parce que pour le coup je fais
partie des gens qui ne sait pas juste
idéologique mais les tomates d'hiver je
ne supporte plus enfin vraiment il y a
un truc je trouve que les tomates elles
ont même plus de goût en fait
ça c'est pas pour ça non quelques la
quinzaine de juillet août et des tomates
d'Espagne
et en général quand comme moi vous en
mettez dans votre jardin quand même
elles arrivent quand vous êtes en
vacances en fait en août donc voilà faut
rater un peu déborder sur septembre quel
est le plat qui vous ferait traverser
tout Paris sur les genoux sur les genoux
Saint-Jacques-de-Compostelle quand je
suis à Paris pour le coup ce qui
m'arrive ce que je fais c'est que je
mange plutôt des choses que je peux pas
trouver dans le Pas-de-Calais en tout
cas dans le bassin mini Pas-de-Calais et
des restaurants grecs des restaurants
libanais
avant le maire de Tours non
alors là on était à des tables mais
c'était vraiment enfin c'est voilà des
réfugiés qui ont ouvert un restaurant
c'était vraiment et quoi beaucoup de
excellents c'est là j'ai mangé une sorte
de d'omelette mais en fait c'était un
œuf brouillé avec de la tomate de la
coriandre des de la feta d'ailleurs et
du thé à la garnamon et enfin voilà
c'est ça etc il y a tout ça mais c'est
vrai que en fait il y a plein de pays où
on mange beaucoup plus de végétariens
que qu'en France pour le coup et ça
permet de varier aussi vous trouvez
qu'en France on a le choix sur les les
menus végétariens qui a suffisamment
d'offres dans les restes alors non mais
je vais vous dire maintenant quand
j'arrive dans un des formes envie dans
des restos végétariens exprès et en fait
je suis complètement déstabilisé parce
qu'il y a trop de choix moi qui suis
habituée à prendre le plat végétarien du
resto en fait on est habitué voilà à
prendre ça et là quand notre vous arrive
dans un resto végétarien vous avez le
choix entre toutes les pages j'ai pu
l'habitude en fait de il y a trop de
choix finalement mais donc on arrive
très bien à remplacer les protéines
animales aujourd'hui mais je peux vous
dire en 2009 quand je suis venu
végétarienne ben dans le restaurant dans
dans le nord c'était très compliqué
vraiment et je me rappelle d'un repas il
vous savez des repas par les assauts et
tout c'est hyper convivial mais
forcément c'est les repas imposés et je
m'étais inscrite à un repas des plus tu
as un repas des aînés ou un repas d'une
assaut de quartier en leur disant par
contre je suis végétarienne et puis le
monsieur m'est vraiment hyper gentil
mais vous inquiétez pas on va trouver
une solution on remplacera la viande par
du jambon ce qui avait vraiment enfin
c'était un concept très exotique d'être
végétarien et donc il y avait une
méconnaissance puis après mais alors du
coup comment vous faites le poisson
comment vous faites avec les œufs est-ce
que vous en mangez vous en mangez pas
vous mangez rien de tout ça si vous avez
6 mois en fait donc je mange les œufs de
mes poules d'accord j'ai deux poules
Peppa et trop trop qui ont été nommés
vous imaginez par mon fils et pas par
moi et et donc ça je mange les œufs de
mes poules mais c'est vrai que en fait
mieux vous mangez plus vous faites
attention plus vous êtes déstabilisé
quand vous voyez arriver dans votre
assiette un œuf dont vous savez pas d'où
venait mais en fait du coup vous savez
d'où il vient quand même comment il a
été élevé quand vous travaillez sur ces
sujets quand vous voyez les vidéos de
L214 moi notamment quand j'avais vu
Brigitte gauthiere la première fois donc
qui est qui fait partie de ses lanceurs
d'alerte qui ont été filmées dans les
abattoirs dans les élevages industriels
c'est des qui sont vegan pour le coup
vraiment par conviction et vraiment sans
entorse et je me dis mais comment quelle
force il faut quand vraiment tu ne
supportes pas la souffrance animale qui
est très sensible à ça que tu supportes
même pas d'en manger pour te faire
embaucher incognito 6 mois dans un
abattoir avec la caméra donc en plus en
prenant des risques quand même il y en a
plusieurs qui ont été repérés dans les
enquêtes suivantes c'était le mari de
Brigitte Gauthier en l'occurrence qui
faisait le reportage en question et je
me disais mais vous avez une force
incroyable moi je pense que je
n'arriverai pas à être dans cette
atmosphère six mois comme ça à faire ce
travail j'arriverai pas parce que vous
transmettez à votre fils là puisque vous
avez l'air quand même un peu
très très à cheval sur certaines choses
est-ce que vous essayez de faire de
faire de lui un vegan ou pas du tout il
a sa liberté mais vous lui montrez
produits transformés produits de la
ferme le distinguer entre tout ça vous
faites de la pédagogie avec lui
les enfants on apprend un peu à cuisiner
on leur montre les choses et après moi
je veux pas imposer mes choix mes
enfants ni à quiconque autour de moi mon
conjoint mange aussi un peu de viande
voilà et donc chacun fait ce qu'il veut
en réalité c'est marrant parce que j'ai
souvent là j'étais encore hier
il va un repas et il y a deux personnes
qui venaient me dire en disant mais nous
on mange de la viande mais de moins en
moins mais en fait on prend quand même
un peu moins l'avion donc ça compense ça
comprend rien du tout rassurez-vous mais
du coup je disais mais pourquoi vous
venez me dire ça genre j'ai l'impression
d'être confessionnal et les gens
viennent me faire leur rédemption qu'ils
ont demandé de la viande et les
écologistes qui sont un peu radicaux
quand même il faut le dire oui mais moi
je donne jamais de leçon à personne ça
se trouve que les gens mangent de la
viande en fait je pense que tout le
monde a bien compris aujourd'hui un
qu'on en mangeait beaucoup trop
c'est-à-dire que quand les gens disent
mais si les gens ils les végétariens ils
sont mauvaises santé parce qu'ils
mangent pas de viande c'est pas
équilibré leur truc bon ok rassurez-vous
on va très bien mais moi même quand
j'étais enceinte on disait vous allez
accoucher à dentaire mais votre bébé
sera rachitique et il est né cinq jours
après terme à 4 kg 150 tout se passait
très bien mais vous voyez il y a des
gens qui qui mangent de la viande en
nous disant mais moi je revendique c'est
bon pour la santé en fait on sait qu'en
France on en mange trop par personne et
que c'est beaucoup c'est pas bon pour la
santé ni pour le porte-monnaie ni pour
la dignité animale
mange pas non plus de façon énorme non
mais au dessus mais vraiment au dessus
des recommandations sanitaires des
préconisations c'est vrai que moi
souvent on dit les écolos ils sont
caricaturaux et tout ça moi je donne
l'effet c'est qu'on est au-dessus des
recommandations sanitaires on mange trop
de viande par rapport à ce qui serait
bon pour la santé mais par ailleurs
chacun fait ce qu'il veut c'est-à-dire
que les gens savent je pense que de plus
en plus sont conscients de l'impact que
ça sur l'eau par exemple le maïs quand
on dit c'est la sécheresse cet été il y
a le maïs irrigué oui mais c'est pour
manger ok mais plus de 80% du maïs qui
est cultivé en France irrigué c'est pour
l'alimentation animale et donc derrière
c'est la consommation de viande et je
dis pas que les gens qui mangent la
viande sont tous des criminels qui
devraient aller se fouetter aller manger
un petit peu de viande
comme quand on achète des vêtements
ceux qui aiment bien acheter plein de
vêtements tout le temps et les mettre
que deux fois savent bien que c'est pas
bon pour la planète ceux qui mangent de
la viande à outrance en m'envoyant parce
que vous savez il y a une petite
communauté viriliste sur les réseaux
sociaux qui m'envoient leurs photos de
grosses têtes c'est bon on a compris
vous mangez des Grosses Têtes ça a l'air
de vous faire très plaisir moi j'ai
jamais dit qu'on allait interdire tout
ça je dis juste que il faut que ce soit
raisonné que par exemple ça me paraît
pas complètement Ding que dans les
cantines dans la restauration collective
les écoles les EHPAD partout les gens
puissent avoir le choix avec une
alternative végétarienne on n'a pas dit
qu'on allait forcer les gens à manger
végétarien on dit juste que les enfants
qui le souhaitent par exemple qui
c'était mon cas à l'époque n'aimait pas
trop la viande moi je n'ai jamais réussi
à manger de la viande à la cantine et
déjà de base très bonne viande non plus
oui mais c'était pas pour le coup je
pense que quand on est en 6e à l'époque
c'était en 2000 enfin 98 très exactement
je me rappelle parce que c'est la
couleur est de lance champion de France
surtout donc en 90 moi j'étais pas en
mode la viande le climat juste ça me
donnait pas envie je voyais l'animal
j'étais pas donc la Cour des comptes
elle a raison quand elle dit qu'il faut
réduire l'élevage de bovins par exemple
en France évidemment et vous voyez c'est
pas des écologistes qui le disent c'est
des gens qui s'occupent exclusivement de
des politiques publiques de leur
évaluation financière donc mais derrière
un discours aussi pour les agriculteurs
parce que une fois qu'on a mis ça sur la
table
aussi beaucoup de l'élevage non mais moi
je vais vous dire j'entends beaucoup de
leçons de morale de les écolos les boucs
émissaires de la misère du qui aiment
pas les agriculteurs les agriculteurs il
y en a quatre fois moins aujourd'hui
qu'il y a 40 ans il y a 200
exploitations chaque semaine en France
qui disparaissent et le revenu moyen
dans un agriculteurs
de ce pays gagnent moins de 560 € par an
et par mois et c'est pas de la faute des
écologistes les gens qui disent
franchement on n'a jamais été en charge
des politiques agricoles et celles et
ceux qui prétendent que les ennemis de
l'agriculture sont les écologistes
mentent cherchent un bouquet mystère
parce qu'en fait ils sont face à leur
propre incompétence face à la propre
impasse dans laquelle ils ont mis ce
modèle productiviste et on en est là
donc moi je trouve que c'est très facile
de dire ça et souvent que ce que je dise
agriculteurs parce que je fais pas mal
de déplacements je suis allé au sein de
la culture je l'ai rencontré au
grand-parents
mais même ceux qui sont pas d'accord
avec moi j'ai pas de problème avec ça on
discute et on travaille et on avance et
en fait voilà il se rendent bien compte
que qu'on n'y est pour rien et
d'ailleurs vous pourriez supprimer tous
les écologistes de France et même
d'Europe et même du monde il y aurait
quand même un problème avec la ressource
en eau quand même un problème avec le
climat et dans une France à 4 degrés ce
qu'on se prépare à vivre d'ici 2100 bah
en fait oui on pourra pas cultiver la
même chose au même endroit et on voit
bien que de toute manière c'est pas
durable moi je rappelle souvent que les
enfants qui naissent en 2023 on ne sait
pas leur garantir que la planète sera
encore habitable quand ils auront 30 ans
et donc voilà
productiviste c'est ce qui nous fait
vivre aujourd'hui aussi c'est ce qui
nous permet de moins important moi
j'entends souvent il nous faut bien
manger bah oui mais je pense que les
gens ont vu aussi de manger bien et il y
a derrière ça toute une une ségrégation
aussi sociale moi quand on me dit que il
faut produire plus parce que mais en
fait c'est produire quoi comment on en
parlera tout à l'heure quand on parlera
de l'échec du bio mais vous voyez bien
que toutes ces productions ça des
externalités y compris sur notre santé à
la fin et moi je ne suis pas d'accord
aujourd'hui de voir ce qu'on fait manger
y compris les scandales sur l'aide
alimentaire européenne où c'était en
fait des steaks de cheval trafiqués
c'est un steak haché où il y avait quand
même pas beaucoup de viande de bœuf à la
fin de danse quand on parle des additifs
ni traits par exemple dans les nitrites
dans la charcuterie on voit on voit bien
c'est des landsesses pareil c'est
l'autorité qui fait référence en matière
de santé eux-mêmes disent on a un sujet
avec ça en France aujourd'hui les gens
ont s'intoxiquent c'est pas bon pour
leur santé il y a une explosion de
cancer colorectal et le lien est fait
enfin un moment il faut se poser ces
questions là et le lobby agroalimentaire
n'aime pas se remettre en question j'ai
l'impression que moi en tant qu'ecologie
je dois le faire en permanence et il y a
pas de problème je le fais déjà été dans
la première quinquennat d'Emmanuel
Macron avec Richard rameaux et alors on
en est où et pour l'instant ça et
franchise
maintenant dans les rayons non alors oui
mais c'est vrai que c'est plus cher et
il faudrait aussi peut-être que les
députés écologistes n'en parle ici à
l'Assemblée mais figurez-vous que
Francesca Pasquini a non pas déposé une
proposition de loi mais défendu une
proposition là dans l'hémicycle pendant
la niche écologiste
mais moins bons sur les solutions
parfois
mais nos solutions moi je refuse qu'on
me dise on est bon sur le constat mais
pas sur les solutions puisqu'on arrive
aujourd'hui aux solutions oui mais c'est
faux c'est que on a peut-être le préjugé
que les écolos il est pas sérieux mais
les solutions qu'on nous présente en
général 20 ans après c'est celle qu'on
disait 20 ans avant en étant moqué quand
on dit encore pendant la campagne qu'il
faut un ISF climatique c'est-à-dire
taxer les patrimoines les plus riches
pour aider à sauver le climat en se
moque de nous mais
c'est un rapport alors qu'il est
conseillé de Macron et lui quand il dit
c'est très intelligent sauf que ces
trois ans après et qu'on a perdu du
temps et sur les Nitril vous me dites
vous en parlez pas on a déposé dans la
niche écologie
du travail on va continuer à parler tous
ces sujets bien sûr après je voudrais
juste qu'on parle de cette bière que
vous nous avez apporté en plus qui est
une bière qui s'appelle la Belus c'est
ça une guerre une guerre blonde qui
existe en plusieurs variétés galop bien
de printemps la bière de Noël la blonde
la brune
c'est la fusion de devis il y avait
énormément Lietar donc c'était vraiment
la commune minière et puis il y avait
Beaumont en Artois qui était plus rural
à côté et quand les mines ferment il
faut reconvertir essayer
d'industrialiser pour pas pour avoir de
une fois et donc il y a la fusion des
deux communes pour qu'il n'aita récupère
en fait du foncier pour pouvoir
implanter des entreprises et donc moi
j'ai deux grands-parents qui étaient en
état et deux de bons moments en Artois
et donc fusion et mais nous on dit
encore on va à Beaumont alors que
maintenant c'est la même ville quoi mais
c'est le côté un peu dommage elle est
familiale je crois alors c'est un petit
cousin donc c'est la ferme à côté de mes
grands-parents je crois que nos
grands-mères étaient cousines voilà et
donc Thomas qui est un peu plus jeune
que moi il a l'âge de mon petit frère et
en fait il a fait le lycée agricole etc
il a décidé de
monter sur la taille de médaillée de
bronze il y a eu 10 médailles du salon
de l'agriculture au fur et 2020 voilà
parce que souvent on assiste à des gens
parler avec Brigitte sur la bière il y a
des agriculteurs qui produisaient des
céréales de l'orge par exemple et qui du
coup
élargissent leur activité monte une
brasserie sur la place
ce que fait votre cousin ou pas non là
c'est enfin c'est son père est encore
exploitant lui reprend pas la ferme pour
l'instant il s'occupe de la brasserie
mais c'est vendu à la ferme en vente
directe
plus compliqué que ça mais pour le coup
c'est vendu sur l'affaire mais c'est les
gens viennent vraiment acheter sur place
mais aussi distribué maintenant de plus
en plus on la trouve un peu les magasins
à Paris aussi non je pense pas encore
peut-être je pense pas mais je pense que
si on veut vraiment s'en procurer il y a
moyen de le faire il y a vous tapez Belu
sur Internet
on va voir si vous êtes vraiment
incollable maintenant c'est le quiz
attention
alors vous qui plaidez la cause des
écolos tel un avocat vous devez être
incollable sur le guacamole vers comme
votre partie seriez-vous
ça mais les avocats
c'est compliqué c'est vrai ça consomme
beaucoup d'eau mais il y en a maintenant
aussi s'il en Espagne seriez-vous donc
nous dire si c'est affirmations sont
vraies ou fausses a le guacamole est une
recette ancestrale des Mayas
c'est vrai alors c'est fou ce sont les
Aztèques au 13e siècle
c'est une question géographique
ce sont les archéologues qui ont trouvé
des traces
d'avocats B ce sont les conquistadors
espagnols qui vont rajouter des oignons
dans sa composition
en fait des Aztèques et non pas les
Maliens faisaient juste du guacamole les
Espagnols ont rajouté leurs petites
touches aux États-Unis l'événement qui a
fait exploser l'importation d'avocats
pour le guacamole et la cérémonie des
Oscars
parce que vous savez il te crampouille
leur petite chips dans le guacamole de
devant la télé
[Musique]
100 millions de kilos en 2021 ont été
achetés pour faire du guacamole
historiquement il y a un moment tout
d'un coup tout le monde s'est mis à
manger du guacamole je ne comprenais pas
la question mais je te fais c'est qu'à
un moment il y a une histoire des
biocarburants beaucoup et que ça fait
exploser le cours des céréales et qui a
eu une grosse inflation sur les
tortillas et qui avait une crise entre
les États-Unis et l'Amérique du Sud à
cause de ça il y a eu une flambée en
2021 mais c'est vrai tous les super
beaux il y a beaucoup de beaucoup de
guacamole enfin en 2015 le New York
Times fait scandale en proposant une
recette de guacamole incluant des petits
pois est-ce que c'est vrai ou faux c'est
un truc vegan écolo bobo encore ça à mon
avis c'est vrai et c'était au bazar non
au Baba lui il avait fait du bruit
exit les petits pois
alors vous allez pouvoir vous rattraper
un petit peu vous qui avez effectué de
Longages à l'ambassade de France à
Stockholm vous connaissez forcément les
spécialités suédoises ah bah le saumon
et les patates et puis voilà si ces
affirmations sont vraies ou fausses pour
vous ça va être facile alors à sur mon
gravlax signifie saumon mariné oui
était enterré pour le conserver
en fait mais il est pas il est beaucoup
il est pas fumé
mais brigitte a raison il était enterré
et le mot gravlax vient d'enterrer non
pas de Mariner ah mais non on fait des
cuisses pointus
les coups de Bulard les fameuses
boulettes de viande Bullard
les fameuses boulettes de viande sont
servies avec une sauce à la groseille
c'est des Airelles mais c'est
l'équivalent c'est des baies voilà c'est
faux j'en mangeais pas en fait
[Rires]
le célèbre peint Vasa est né en Suède il
y a 5 siècles est-ce que c'est vrai ou
est-ce que c'est faux
je peux vous dire qu'elle a la plus
grosse course de ce qu'ils te font au
monde c'est la vasalopette la course
il y a des îles qui s'appelle comme ça
etc mais alors est-ce que c'est un pain
est-ce qu'il a été emporté au 15e siècle
je n'en sais rien alors c'est vrai c'est
bien nuancé il y a 5 siècles et c'est à
base de seigle c'est un pain dur qui a
conserver en fait et puis les pommes de
terre rôties assez bac vous dites comme
ça sont découpés en cubes
ça n'a aucun sens vos questions si vous
les achetez au supermarché j'ai un truc
en plastique comme ça peut-être mais en
vrai c'est plutôt elles sont servies en
fait
c'est une vraie recette suédoise et on
les prépare d'une manière un peu
particulière
grenailles elles sont un peu exactement
en robe des champs comme on dirait on
peut on peut accorder le point oui mais
les vrais suédois les découpes en
éventail mais c'est pas en cube enfin en
cube c'est si vous achetez surgelés dans
le truc ce compte faire le bac
congélation
politique et bien souvent le repas
occupe une assez large place et c'est
souvent là que ce nous les deals
politiques et que se fait la petite et
la grande histoire c'est la brève de
comptoir
alors pendant que vous mangez une frite
on vous a demandé de réfléchir à un
souvenir politique
autour d'un repas est-ce que vous avez
une histoire à nous raconter j'en ai
plein qui sont pas racontables
les meilleurs moments militants parce
que faut se dire que quand on écolo
c'est pas tous les jours simples mais ce
qui nous rassemble ce qui nous fait dire
c'est qu'on rencontre vraiment des gens
super qui savent pourquoi ils font ça et
moi je sais que ce qui a beaucoup forgé
aussi mon ma détermination à me dire
c'est je suis au bon endroit et je vais
continuer et c'est pour pour elle pour
eux pour tout le monde qu'on se bat
c'est les grands repas de d'agriculture
paysanne en fait qu'on organise en
Pas-de-Calais vous savez la
Confédération paysanne je peux dire que
bio dans le Pas-de-Calais c'est pas
hyper
hyper facile dans la vie mais il y en a
qui l'ont fait très tôt qui ont
défricher ce chemin que bientôt tout le
monde devrait emprunter ils sont très
courageux et en fait donc on il y a la
fête de l'agriculture paysanne on met un
peu à l'honneur c'est savoir faire on
teste vous savez les désherbeuses à la
main parce qu'il y a pas les pesticides
on rencontre un peu tout le monde les
gens échangent sur leur métier et en
général ça se termine par un repas un
peu auberge espagnole ou chacun ramenait
son fromage son pain c'est ses endives
on est bien en or et c'est des moments
hyper sympa qui donne du sens en fait à
tout ce qu'on fait nous côté politique
au côté paysan il y a aussi des
syndicats évidemment il y a des
associations et c'est le moment où voilà
on se rassemble et on célèbre un peu
tous les combats qu'on mène et pourquoi
on les mène voilà ça donne beaucoup de
sens et c'est très très fédérateur alors
on va avancer dans cette émission et on
va parler de l'inflation qui pèse sur le
portefeuille des ménages en matière
alimentaire le poireau bio ne fait plus
recette celle de sous des plats
des centaines de poireaux mais à
disposition gratuitement pour les
habitants et les associations voilà
l'opération qui a eu lieu récemment dans
l'Oise avec l'inflation le bio voit son
chiffre d'affaires chuter trop cher et
les délaissés comme ces poireaux ce qui
oblige des agriculteurs à repasser en
conventionnelle reportage Hélène
Bonduelle et nos confrères de France
Télévisions
récolte un peu particulière chez ceux
maraîcher bio cueillette de poireaux
gratuites pour tout le monde tout doit
disparaître c'est très gentil de sa part
de faire ce geste parce qu'en fait il
est pas obligé
de poireaux aujourd'hui et vu ce qu'on
nous donne ce qu'on peut prendre
aujourd'hui ça fait quand même des
secrets économiques
40 tonnes de légumes invendus Stéphane
Remond n'a pas eu le choix plutôt que de
les faire partir à la benne il a préféré
les offrir
[Musique]
on a une chute de vente en agriculture
biologique voilà qui a fait que on se
retrouve avec des volumes notamment de
poireaux d'autres légumes aussi sur les
bras car avec l'inflation les
consommateurs se détournent du bio ces
produits ne s'écoulent plus et les
chambres froides croule sous les stocks
de légumes là en stock une qui aurait dû
déjà être vendu là pendant l'hiver des
coups de production ou trop élevés des
commandes qui s'effondrent les
maraîchers ont même dû se séparer de
plusieurs salariés en vie il travaille
la situation on a redressement
judiciaire suite à cette situation de
crise
on espère pouvoir rebondir
ce sont nos convictions qui en prennent
un coup l'idée aujourd'hui c'est de se
dire comment comment on va sur quoi on
va rebondir quoi leur conviction c'est
marrer chez bio depuis deux générations
ont donc décidé de les mettre de côté
quelques temps c'est des carottes là qui
vont pousser donc avant c'était une
parcelle qui était en bio et aujourd'hui
c'est une parcelle qui va être conduite
en non bio d'ici quelques semaines
engrais et pesticides reviendront sur
cette exploitation et ils ne sont pas
les seuls l'an dernier
3380 agriculteurs se sont déconvertis
contre 2510 en 2021
alors pour soutenir la filière le
ministre de l'Agriculture a annoncé un
deuxième plan d'urgence pour 60 millions
d'euros
des mesures de court terme pour gérer
l'urgence pour éviter les déconversions
des mesures de moyen terme qui
s'adressent tout autant à ceux qui sont
déjà convertis qu'à ceux qui voudraient
aller vers la conversion en agriculture
biologique parce qu'on a besoin de
redonner et de l'espoir et de la fierté
et ils en ont besoin au producteurs bio
pour leur dire que pour nous c'est l'une
des voix que nous souhaitons encourager
cela sera-t-il suffisant pour enrayer
l'hémorragie et surtout pour que la
France tienne ses engagements
atteindre 18% de surface agricole bio en
2027 contre plus de 10% seulement en
alors marine tandelier est-ce que vous
aussi vous avez délaissé le bio parce
qu'il était trop cher moi je voulais
revenir sur le tout début parce que vous
avez commencé par parler de l'inflation
je vais vous quand même avoir un mot
parce que il y a un Français sur 10
aujourd'hui qui est dans la précarité
alimentaire ça faut le dire et que parmi
les plus précaires en France 40 % c'est
un sondage qui était sorti en avril 40 %
ont supprimé un repas par jour et 53%
ont réduit des portions dans les
assiettes et celle de leur famille c'est
un chiffre qui est assez terrible et
donc il y a un problème d'inflation qui
touche en fait l'alimentaire de manière
générale pour le sujet du bio ce qu'on
voit là c'est que c'est ça devrait être
plus accessible pour tout le monde parce
que moi je ne suis pas d'accord pour
dire en gros il y a l'élite qui a le
droit de manger bien et sain et bio et
local et tout ça et puis oui mais en
fait
la question c'est est-ce que
l'alimentation de qualité accessible à
tout le monde ou est-ce qu'on condamne
finalement 40 millions de Français à
manger de l'agro industriels les
pesticides sont même trop toujours
savoir exactement ce qu'on mange
massivement que je voulais vous dire sur
le sur le bio il faut bien comprendre
que lobbio ça se prête très mal au
calcule juste économique aujourd'hui on
installe capitaliste et donc il y a
l'offre il y a la demande et vous voyez
comment ça peut marcher le bio c'est
bien plus que ça parce que je prends
l'exemple d'une salade je vous donne des
chiffres de 2020 donc ça évolué avec
l'inflation mais une salade bio vous la
payez en 2020 en moyenne en euros une
salade conventionnelle pas bio vous la
payez en moyenne 70 centimes donc vous
pouvez dire bah c'est vachement mieux
c'est moins cher sauf que la salade
accrochez-vous bien à 70 centimes
combien coûtait la société c'est mon
quiz maintenant pour vous ce que vous
savez combien elle coûte à la société
non mais j'imagine en terme de sécurité
sociale si on s'est entre eux entre 17
et 27 euros parce que vous prenez en
compte les problèmes de santé la
dépollution de l'eau qu'on paye tous
comme citoyens par nos cotisations
d'usagers pour l'agence de l'eau le
climat parce que ce que ça implique pour
le climat les déchets et évidemment les
coûts pour la pour la santé pour la
sécurité sociale c'est-à-dire que quand
on nous dit le bio le modèle économique
sur l'air sur l'eau etc mais elle coûte
beaucoup plus cher au producteurs en
termes de main d'oeuvre mais ce que je
veux vous dire c'est que ce calcul est
complètement artificiel on est en fait
dans une concurrence déloyale entre une
conventionnelle qui en fait très très
largement subventionné par mais y
compris par les aides la Pâques
européenne qui est en France a des
critères spéciaux qui favorisent même si
quand même la Pâque a deux il y a deux
volières le premier volet et vous êtes
en fait très encouragés quand vous êtes
productiviste c'est des aides à
l'hectare si vous par exemple si vous
êtes éleveur que vous produisez du soja
pour nous intensif irriguer pour nourrir
vos élevage vous êtes beaucoup mieux
financé par la Pâque que si vous faites
du pâturage par exemple c'est comme ça
c'est les critères et que j'applique
l'Europe et la France et donc vous êtes
déjà très desservé là-dessus et donc
bien sûr quand vous êtes bien vous avez
une petite aide en plus mais qui ne
compensent jamais l'aide que vous ratez
sur ce volet avec des aides à la
conversion là avec aussi des régions
alors voilà maintenant on nous dit nous
on démocratie on fait haute valeur
environnementale
environnementale ça ne veut rien dire
par exemple y avoir des pesticides dans
le HD mais il y en a quasiment toujours
d'ailleurs quelqu'un qui crée une aire
de nettoyage de lavage pour son
pulvérisateur sur sa ferme à le label HD
quelqu'un qui change rien à sa manière
de produire mais qui te met trois
panneaux solaires sur son hangar ce qui
est très bien va être HV et donc vous
achetez des produits HBe qui qui n'ont
rien de dans ce que vous avez dans
l'assiette de spécifiquement
environnemental et donc c'est très grave
ce qui est en train de se passer parce
que on est un moment où jamais les gens
ne l'ont autant conscience de l'urgence
climatique sanitaire biodiversité etc et
et en fait on décidère le bio les
politiques publiques s'aiment la
confusion et vous avez là un ministre
que je trouve au compte dans le de
l'hypocrisie parce que les politiques
publiques c'est pas moi qui les mène
c'est lui et donc quand on voit qu'on
présente le bio comme ah mais c'est très
largement subventionné sinon c'est pas
rentable excusez-moi si on prenait en
compte le coût pour la société et les
externalités négatives des externalités
tout court d'ailleurs des productions de
bio est largement plus vertueux y
compris économiquement sanitairement
environnementalement tout que le
conventionnelle c'était pas on a très
peu d'endroits on peut la voir en France
vous connaissez le poids du lobby enfin
c'est des sujets dont c'est très très
difficile de parler je suis contente
vous voyez bien que le ministère de
l'Agriculture il travaille main dans la
main avec certains syndicats agricoles
qui c'est quasiment une cogestion on le
dit parfois et moi je dis ça j'ai rien
contre l'agriculteur qui défendent leur
métier là je sais dans quelles
conditions ils vivent c'est pas eux le
problème je pense pas que ce soit les
écologistes non plus mais à un moment il
faut ouvrir la voie il y a un
agriculteur qui se suicide tous les deux
jours il y a 200 exploitations qui
ferment chaque semaine en France qui
disparaisse nous on a un projet
mais nous on veut redonner à ce métier
et aujourd'hui en fait je pense que ça
ne va personne et par ailleurs sur le
bio vous dites il y a pas assez de de
consommation en fait nous dans les
villes écologistes on prend nos
responsabilités la ville de Lyon à la
fin du mandat en 2026 sera à 100% de bio
dans la cantine et 50% produit
localement dans un rayon de moins de 200
km et accessible pour tout le monde
parce que les prix vont pas augmenter
même plutôt il baisse parce qu'on réduit
gaspillage etc c'est ça qu'il faut faire
et ça c'est bien pour les enfants c'est
bien pour les parents c'est bien pour
les agriculteurs donc il faut le faire
localement alors ça peut ça peut être
local et ça n'est pas national ça vous
voyez la loi égalime qui a été votée qui
disait il faut 20% de bio dans la
cantine en 2020 vous savez combien on
était en 2020 à 6 %, c'est à dire que ce
pays fixe toujours des objectifs mais ne
le respectent même 20 % de son pas
encore atteint et à la fin on n'est pas
juste une question c'est pas compatible
avec un système capitaliste puisque
c'est bien ce que j'ai compris
le système pour encourager le bio à
construire autour du bio en fait je
pense qu'il faut que il faut des non il
faut des politiques publiques très
courageuses qui montrent aux gens très
publiquement mais c'est la Cour des
comptes qu'il dit donc je vais dire il
faut sortir les rapports qui dit votre
salade 1 euro en fait elle coûte 27% la
société et c'est quand même vous qui
payez à la fin c'est toujours nous qui
payons à la fin et voilà rééquilibrer du
coup les prix nous on demande aussi un
chèque alimentaire 250 euros de ne plus
exister autour de du marché des salades
qu'est-ce qu'on fait et bien sûr qu'on
peut faire pourquoi on est les derniers
de d'Europe sur des sujets là tous les
autres arrivent sauf nous je suis à la
manière dont les aides à la Pâques sont
après revente cultivés en bio on est les
premiers non mais on est le pays où le
bio et le moins avantagé par la manière
dont la pack est distribué en France ça
c'est un fait bah c'est des politiques
publiques donc c'est un vrai problème et
derrière c'est pas que la sieste la
santé etc c'est le nombre de pesticides
vous savez en pesticides on avait dit
qu'on allait entre
2009 et 2018 on devait baisser de 50%
pesticides en France est-ce qu'il y
avait été annoncé publiquement vous
savez combien on a fait plus 20% de
pesticides vendus sur cette période
alors qu'on devait baisser de 50 % et à
la fin au bout de la chaîne on a 800
millions d'oiseaux qui ont disparu en
Europe entre les années 80 et
aujourd'hui et c'est très largement à
cause de ça à cause de l'agriculture
productiviste et donc c'est 20 millions
d'oiseaux qui disparaît chaque année 25%
des oiseaux ont disparu en Europe depuis
les années 80 60 % des oiseaux des
champs c'est Caroline Carson qui a écrit
un livre là-dessus appelée printemps
silencieux et vous voyez ce silence ces
oiseaux qu'on entend plus pour nous et
quand c'est du Bio produit moins
alors comment on fait pour nourrir toute
la population si on produit moins si on
importe nouvelle on installe plus de
paysans et nous ce qu'on prône chez les
écologistes qu'on a défendu à la
présidentielle et qu'on continuera de
défendre il y a un collectif nourrir
aussi qui rassemble plein d'assauts qui
défend ça c'est un million de paysans en
France d'ici 2050
personne ne dit ça il y a que vous qui
dites
magique donc si vous voulez bien on va
essayer de faire autre chose et la
réalité c'est que d'ici 2025 de d'ici
2050 c'est possible que ça crée plus
d'emplois parce que les vous allez
aujourd'hui on a des aides à l'hectare
etc la réalité c'est que c'est pas vrai
que les paysans vivent mieux avec ce
système on produisent plus mais pour les
grandes exploitations si mais pas pour
les petits il faut être un très gros et
en fait c'est un système qui est fort
avec les avec les faibles les faibles
avec l'effort donc ça ne va pas que ça
se négocie au niveau européen non parce
que la PAC c'est une aide européenne et
un cadre européen mais chaque pays est
assez libre de ce qu'il en fait il y a
beaucoup de marges de manoeuvre au
ministère de l'Agriculture la manière
dont la France a fait cela ce qui
s'applique depuis le 1er janvier 2023
oui est un vrai sujet qui et vous voyez
la ministre dit c'est pas juste oh là là
on va trouver des solutions mais c'est
bien leurs critères qui aboutissent à ça
aujourd'hui et c'est ça responsabilité
de mise parce que si c'est pas de sa
faute à lui alors je sais pas mais il
faut que ça se passe en douceur aussi
parce que sinon les acides en fait ça
fait 40 ans vous voyez le chiffre sur
les sur les oiseaux c'est le plus années
80 Caroline Carson qui dit printemps
silencieux qui parle les oiseaux etc son
livre il est de 1962 donc moi je ne peux
plus entendre que faut que ça se fasse
en douceur etc et qui évidemment il faut
que ça s'annonce douceur mais c'est un
argument pour ne le faire jamais et je
vais vous dire à force de le faire
jamais ça va se faire pas en douceur du
tout et pas par des politiques publiques
quand il va faire plus 4 degrés en fait
ça va pas être en douceur du tout quand
il n'y aura plus d'eau cet été ça va pas
être en douceur du tout la nature à un
moment va reprendre ses droits ses
droits et franchement ça va être très
dur pour tout le monde très très dur
pour tout le monde y compris pour les
agriculteurs qui vont vivre un été très
différents
le Sri Lanka a essayé de se convertir au
100% bio c'était une révolution on avait
dit c'est formidable finalement ça a été
un échec épouvantable les paysans comme
le disait Brigitte ne produisait pas
assez ne gagnez pas assez on produisait
pas assez pour la population locale il y
a pas de souveraineté ça c'est
complètement effondré donc c'est un peu
plus compliqué que vous dites en fait
j'ai l'impression qu'il y a un cynisme
ambiant ou faut démontrer que ça marche
jamais
il y a un truc il y a toujours quelqu'un
qui est super content de me démontrer
que ça n'a pas marché
la figure quand même vous me donnez ça
pour dire du coup ça marche pas donc on
continue mais on peut pas continuer le
système actuel est voué à l'échec on est
dans une vraie impasse et c'est un
moment une
erreur politique lourde que de le nier
que de promettre aux agriculteurs qu'on
les aime et qu'on va tout faire pour que
ça change pas ça changera degré ou de
force et pas du fait des écolos on vous
dit que oui il y a des chemins d'espoir
qui sont possibles ça ça marche le mieux
dans plein d'endroits il y a pas de
raison qu'on soit le dernier pays
d'Europe à aider le bio c'est par
exemple ça c'est pas normal c'est un
vrai parti pris politique qui a des
conséquences lourdes et donc nous nous
battrons pour défendre alors on va
continuer de toute façon qui la
produisent et celles qui pourront y
avoir accès c'est-à-dire tout le monde
par un chèque alimentaire qui soit
accessible à tout le monde une vraie
sécurité sociale alimentaire parce que
l'alimentation c'est bien plus que
d'alimentation derrière c'est la santé
j'imagine c'est quand même interview
exactement pour au moins accès à des
produits de qualité ce sera déjà entendu
alors après l'agriculture on va évoquer
l'élevage et le bien-être animal avec la
construction d'un poulailler géant dans
l'Yonne on en parle et on met les pieds
dans le plat
on est en train de sortir des termes il
y en a d'autres donc ce sont ces méga
poulaillés de la discorde à plusieurs
hangars abritant 40 000 poulets voir 90
000 devrait bientôt voir le jour dans
l'Yonne pour produire des volailles bon
marché mais leur construction suscite la
polémique avec un tas d'inquiétude pour
les populations voisines c'est un
reportage signé France Télévisions avec
Pierre Michael corniel
[Musique]
des tonnes de terre retirées à la
tractopelle dans l'Yonne ce champ
retourné est au cœur d'une polémique la
construction d'un poulailler pouvant
accueillir jusqu'à 40 000 volailles
Eric Bourdon est céréalier il n'a jamais
élevé de poulet
pourtant le projet est énorme un hangar
aussi long qu'un terrain de football
[Musique]
ce qu'on va se produire c'est les
poulets standards donc on sait très bien
que le poulet standard c'est du poulet
de 41 jours que c'est pas du poulet
élevé en grande plein air c'est pas du
poulet bio c'est pas du poulet label qui
sont produits beaucoup mais on à l'heure
actuelle on fait ça parce que à l'heure
actuelle c'est le marché le demande son
exploitation n'était plus rentable
l'agriculteur a donc accepté l'offre
d'un puissant industriel duc filiale de
l'entreprise néerlandaise plus conne
leader européen de la volaille
selon le céréalier l'industriel prend en
charge la moitié des travaux soit
300.000 euros
[Musique]
dans le village de cergines Le chantier
crée la discorde chez les habitants
hygiène et tout le truc il y a pas de
problème mais c'est vrai si c'est
agréable vous ouvrez vos fêtes
vous sentez le caca poule vous sentez
tout ce que vous voulez bah non donc en
bas je veux pas
tout le monde travaille si tu vois un
problème c'est aussi dur pour lesquelles
agriculteurs que pour nous les retraités
c'est compliqué c'est une honte pourquoi
parce que vous rendez pas compte la
maltraitance des animaux et je sais pas
combien de poules dedans c'est horrible
la crainte numéro 1 des opposants voir
dans leur village ces images
épouvantables filmées par L214 en 2020
dans une autre antenne du groupe duc
pourtant ce projet est défendu par une
majorité des liloko il faut bien se
doter de moyens si on veut répondre à la
demande si on ne le fait pas on va
devoir importer avec les risques
sanitaires que ça comporte je trouve que
c'est une bonne chose pour le
consommateur nos céréaliers et pour
l'économie locale
duc prépare déjà l'arrivée du méga
poulailler en décembre l'entreprise a
reçu toutes les autorisations
préfectorales pour passer de 250 à 400
tonnes de volailles abattu par jour
l'élevage dans l'Yonne commence à son
activité en 2024 mais il a filiale voit
plus grand et projette déjà de
construire dans l'Aube un bâtiment
pouvant accueillir cette fois-ci plus de
90 000 poulets
marine ton denier je me fais l'avocat du
diable ça va créer des emplois les
autorités les pouvoirs les autorités
locales le disent une dame qui dit il
faut bien qu'on travaille le céréalier
qui pouvait pas subvenir à ses besoins
construits ce hangar donc finalement
c'est pas si mal que ça tout n'est pas
acheté on en vient exactement au
problème que je vous décrivais
précédemment c'est que les politiques
publiques font ce monsieur l'explique
très bien un reportage il dit c'était ma
production était plus rentable et quand
vous voyez le nombre de subventions etc
vous voyez bien que c'est c'est lié
aussi à la manière dans ce pays on
rémunère les agriculteurs ou pas et de
l'autre côté il dit là je vais gagner
beaucoup d'argent enfin beaucoup plus
qu'en tout cas aujourd'hui c'est un
calcul économique et pour moi la santé
l'alimentation l'environnement
l'habitabilité de la planète c'est bien
de ça dont il s'agit à la fin et à
horizon dans 30 ans ne peuvent pas être
résumés
soit pu habitable dans 30 ans juste
parce que nos calculs économiques
étaient montré que c'est ça qu'il
fallait faire ça n'a aucun sens ça n'a
aucun sens et donc je ne vous parle même
pas pour le coup de la dignité animale
et du fait qu'on juge le degré de
civilisation d'une société à la manière
dont elle traite ses animaux et ce que
les images qu'on voit dans ces abattoirs
pour pouvoir les soutenir en fait si on
décide de manger du poulet ou de la
viande etc donc faites confiance de
toute façon pour aller jeter un œil dans
cet abattoir poulailler plutôt quand il
sera évidemment mais ils font ça
heureusement qu'ils font ça parce que
beaucoup ça a permis l'évoluer de la
législation des mesures fortes parce que
quand l'opinion publique c'est elle ne
laisse pas faire donc il y a des
évolutions législation mais il y a
toujours ensuite des dérogations sur le
broyage des poussins vous vous rappelez
de L214 ça mais derrière ça il y a aussi
du lobbying il y a aussi le lobbying
vegan derrière c'est L214 et ceux qui
dénoncent le mal-être animal alors que
les problèmes et bah c'est à dire
qu'il y a une boule aux éleveurs
ce que je vous explique c'est qu'il y a
des lobbies dans le milieu énergétique
agroalimentaire dans certains milieux
qui qui pour beaucoup cause des vrais
problèmes humains pour la santé pour
l'environnement qui sont climaticides
etc quand on parle du lobby vegan comme
si c'était les gens à abattre ils le
font de mal à personne ils ont droit de
défendre leur truc et de excusez-moi
quand ils montent ces images moi je
trouve que c'est d'intérêt public que on
connaisse ces images mais ça ça n'a rien
à voir avec l'élevage c'est de
l'industrie c'est faire des processus
industriels avec du vivant comme si
c'était des dogmes un marché vegan
derrière ça il y a quand même on trouve
plein de produits vegan aujourd'hui
et qui est député européen il est
éleveur il fait des vaches il le fait
avec ses méthodes qui sont respectueuses
du vivant
chez animaux
à des poulets bon marché pour des gens
qui ont pas de pouvoir d'achat que
peut-être il faut moins manger de viande
et de meilleures qualités et que je suis
pas d'accord que à chaque fois on dit
c'est parce que ce que vous dites en
fait c'est que c'est de la faute des
pauvres ces élevages
premièrement c'est pas de leur faute et
deuxièmement ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que il y a des gens qui ont le
droit de manger des animaux élevés en
plein air et puis que les pauvres ils
doivent s'ils veulent lui doivent manger
ces trucs dégueulasses dégueulasse pour
les animaux et dégueulasse pour les
humains et pour leur santé donc moi je
ne suis pas d'accord et je trouve que
dans ce pays qui est champion de la
subvention de l'agriculture
et il faut encourager celles et ceux qui
travaillent de manière vertueuse et tous
ensemble oui on peut manger moins de
viande et de meilleure qualité ce sera
mieux pour tout le monde et vraiment je
pense que on arrivait à la limite où
tout le monde voit bien dans son
assiette est-ce qu'un pays réussit ça
dans cette équation est-ce qu'un pays a
réussi c'était quoi
un pays c'est pas hop tout d'un coup ça
se fait déjà c'est pas qu'un problème
français c'est une marche en maison
oui je pense la plupart des pays du
monde dans une grosse grosse majorité
mange beaucoup moins de viande que la
France et il s'en sort parfaitement
au Brésil
aux États-Unis non mais vous confondez
deux choses combien ils mangent par an
et est-ce que ça augmente tout ça
des classes moyennes qui arrivent sur le
marché elle mange et elle consomme de la
viande c'est un vrai problème d'ailleurs
je vous dis qu'on mange beaucoup plus de
viande que les Indiens vous dites vous
me les Indiens ça augmente ok ça
augmente mais vu de où il partait c'est
absolument pas niveau de la France il
faut arrêter à un moment de se dire
qu'en France tout est bien et qui est
toujours un pays qui fait pire ou eux ça
augmente justement
je cherche pas je cherche justement le
pays auprès de vous
inspirer énormément et par ailleurs
énormément sur la viande
je pense que les États-Unis doivent être
au dessus de nous en viande l'Allemagne
les États-Unis font c'est n'importe quoi
les élevages américains on peut pas
discuter comme ça le truc c'est que
premièrement il y a moi je vous parle de
la France là mais c'est un problème
mondial que les économistes américaines
j'allais pas prendre l'Amérique comme
exemple je vous dis qu'on consomme moins
de viande plus de viande que dans la
plupart des pays sauf peut-être les
États-Unis vous avez votre raisonnement
et vous ne m'écoutez pas vous partez sur
moi je vous propose c'est pour ça que je
me suis je vous ai mal compris je veux
un pays dont il faudrait s'inspirer pour
notre politique alimentaire et pourquoi
c'est pas nous qui devrions inspirer les
autres en fait à un moment
on est dans les pires pays du monde là
dessus donc faut arrêter en fait de de
me dire c'est quel pays qui est mieux
c'est quasiment tous les autres ça c'est
simple et par ailleurs il faut qu'on
arrive à être vertueux à développer ce
chemin que de toute manière on devra en
planter je vous dis pas que c'est facile
sinon on l'aurait sûrement déjà fait je
vous dis juste que l'entièreté de cette
humanité ensemble est en train d'aller
dans le mur et qu'on a deux choix
continuer à accélérer en faisant dans la
Cabou fait des grosses steaks en prenant
l'avion et en mettant plein d'eau
partout et on crame tout pendant 10 ans
mais au moins on aura bien vécu où on
essaye de faire en sorte que nos enfants
et nos petits-enfants puissent vivre
c'est pas juste ce qu'ils auront encore
des poulets et qui seront élevés vous
l'avez dit sérieux
c'est terminé en 2030 enfin tout il y a
une il y a une pétition citoyenne
européenne et la Commission a dit en
2030 c'est fin de l'élevage en cage
point c'est pas tolérable en fait
d'avoir de l'élevage comme ça on va se
mettre d'accord on va passer au dessert
hein
et je suis un adepte de la cassonade
mais j'ai l'impression que dans les vous
allez m'arrêter si je vous me trompe
dans les
supermarchés on trouve souvent de la
cassonade de canne à sucre et non pas de
la cassonade de betteraves non bah oui
après c'est pas une marque très mais qui
fait la cassonade qu'on trouve dans les
supermarchés pour le coup c'est ça là
qu'on mange mais c'est vrai que ma
famille tous les dimanches soirs c'est
des crêpes donc là c'est vraiment tous
les dimanches
qui est le bon côté d'en faire plan donc
donc voilà après il y a le débat est-ce
que dans la pâte à crêpes on met de la
bière du rhum alors vous vous mettez de
la bière j'imagine non rien ou de la
bière et à ou de la bière ça fait un peu
effet
pour un nouveau numéro de politique à
table sur LCP
[Musique]